good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2023 2024
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has put a
focus on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to the different themes
in biomedical and Health Sciences our
theme for this year is focused on
building Partnerships for generative
generative AI training in biomedic and
clinical research where every Friday we
will enjoy uh uh talks from a range of
leading thinkers about the issues the
promises the opportunities and the
hurdles associated with the emerging uh
challenges in AI based uh methods
applied to biomedical science data types
um indeed we'd like to make sure that we
mention that the uh to our folks that
our 2023 2024 application cycle is open
and we encourage Junior faculty members
working in areas such as the development
of generative AI based methods applied
to biomedical research and those Junior
faculty actively utilizing AI in their
biomedical teaching should consider
applying we believe this is an exciting
and engaging program bringing together
AI platform developers with University
level Educators to better understand the
power the promise and potential perils
associated with the generative AI
explosion participants selected for our
biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage seminars like this
one as vital materials for our
culminating in-person manuscript and
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the bajia beachfront Resort
located in Sunny San Diego California in
June of
2024 today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Steven bake from the
University of Virginia's School of data
science Dr bake is an associate
professor of data science um where he is
an applied geometer engineer data
scientist with a keen interest in
geometric data analysis he applies
computational differential geometry
computer vision and machine learning to
address problems in physics mechanical
engineering Material Science sports
science and medicine he has been a
principal investigator of various
research projects funded by the federal
government and Industry sponsors such as
the National Science Foundation the
National Institutes of Health the Air
Force the Army NASA Department of
Transportation and Hyundai Motors
amongst others in continuing with our
2023 2024 biomedical data science
seminar series theme Steven's lecture
today is entitled can AI uncover the
laws of physics by observing apples
falling from trees Stephen will tell us
about the moving Beyond mere pattern
recognition um that machines are now
capable of extracting new insights from
hidden Trends and patterns and
generating lifelike images and coherent
text and making complex decision
decisions in intricate environments all
these advances and U all this progress
is happening at an astonishing rate but
it begs the question of whether AI will
eventually attain the level of
intelligence required to delve into
highly intellectual Pursuits like
comprehending the fundamental laws of
physics in this presentation Dr bake
will highlight some of the recent
Frontiers in physics aware deep learning
and demonstrate their application in
solving complex mechanical engineering
problems ranging from designing
composite materials to predicting
Quantum spin Dynamics and consider how
these might be appropriate for their
subsequent use in biom medicine as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
if you're watching on YouTube thank you
so much for joining us also our
specially selected 2023 2024 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants
and alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have um via the uh chat
feature in their YouTube sessions I will
be synthesizing these questions and
asking them on your behalf during the
last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and
with that Stephen welcome we are very
excited to hear your
presentation thank you so much Jack I
appreciate it uh that's a great
introduction um so I think everybody who
is watching this video um would know
what this uh this picture up here means
uh this is a picture of Isaac
Newton um and this famous you know story
about the discovery of the gravity right
so Newton was sitting in uh under the
tree and then there's you know all of a
sudden Apple you know fall on the
ground uh and then you know Newton was
thinking you know if the Apple falls
down you know from the tree while the
moon you know stays up there what is the
governing physics um you know defining
all this uh you know phenomena in in in
our world was kind of the question that
he Ponder and then you know as a result
of that he discovered the law of uh you
know the physical law governing the the
universe of gravitation which is the the
equation that you're seeing over
here so as a data scientist I have a
similar question uh so let's say you
know we have a machine or a robot OT or
a computer algorithm and then we show an
apple falling from the tree and then we
ask the robot to uh figure out what the
governing law uh of that Apple falling
from the tree would be uh of course um
computer algorithms are not that smart
so probably we're going to need a lot of
data so instead of just one apple you
know falling from a tree uh we're going
to need like millions of millions of
apples falling from uh different initial
conditions uh but still the question is
given that there is enough data with uh
machines and you know machine learning
algorithm be able to figure out the
governing Dynamics uh of an apple uh
falling down from the tree so that's
going to be the story that uh I'll be
I'll be telling today um and especially
um you know right now I'm not very
active in the area of biomedical uh
application I'm mostly working on uh
physics problems and Material Science
problems but just to help the audience
to you know connect the dots between
what I do versus uh what you know you
folks are potentially interested I I
brought some examples from uh other
people's Publications so this is not
from my group's uh research but uh one
example of where this kind of physics
could be uh Incorporated and then you
know machine learning algorithms could
potentially be able to understand the
Dynamics is the activities in brain
where um we basically have these
electric signals and you know
activations
um dynamically changing According to
some you know governing equation
defining the the activities of the brain
so if we can collect enough data uh of
the brain functions then the question is
will machine learning algorithms be able
to discover that uh governing equation
uh defining the the brain activities of
the human brain or similarly uh the
Dynamics of cells uh so this example
over here again is from other people's
research but this is a a cancer cell
bics and as you can see a lot of things
are moving around here so uh the
algorithm that I I'm going to present
today is going to be mostly on um things
like fluid dynamics and you know uh the
traditional
mechanics but I feel like you know this
kind of biological Behavior could also
be modeled using some similar physics
governing equations uh where the cell
growth can be represented using uh the
diffusion phenomena uh this is kind of
analogous to the diffusion phenomena in
fluids uh the movements of the cell is
analogous to ection uh sometimes the
cells are you know newly created or
divides or uh or dies out those are kind
of the reactive Dynamics in in in fluids
and again uh if a physics um if a
machine learning algorithm is able to
figure out you know fluid Dynamic
properties and you know uh the movement
of fluids and U things like that then
the similar principle could also be you
know uh applicable to uh the analysis of
biological
cells and here's another uh similar
example where uh the potential kind of
intersection between uh what I'm about
to present and then uh the interest of
the audience so uh here's uh
electrophysiology of the the human heart
and then you can see this
um uh the the electromagnetic field is
uh evolving over time and then uh this
is actually an application of um you
know some some other group in Italy uh
where they applied uh machine learning
algorithm actually to model the the
physic physics Dynamics equation of the
cardiac electr physiology so those are
kind of the potential directions where
uh my presentation May uh intersect with
your world so with that uh my name is
Stephen back I'm associate professor of
data science I am also a mechanical
engineer by training so I I hold a
secondary appointment with the
Department of mechanical and aerospace
engineering here at the University of
Virginia and uh today I'm going to be
presenting uh with the topic of AI
uncover the laws of physics by observing
uh from
data so today since a lot of my work uh
recently has been focused on Material
Science uh I'll be using the material
science example uh in this presentation
but hopefully um you know you'll be able
to connect this um This research with uh
the biomedical applications uh at the
end of the presentation so uh what
you're seeing up here is a material
called hmx hmx is a part of an
explosive uh so this is a highly
energetic material and uh hmx um is
basically used for propellants and
explosives uh in various military and
civilian applications the way it works
is basically um when uh a shock is
applied to hmx the shock will
induce um the collapse of the hmx
crystals and then the microscopic
structures over there and then as those
microscopic structures collapse due to
the shock they will release a huge
chemical energy and then if the energy
released by The the crystals uh this
microscopic structures is large enough
then uh the chemical energy will turn
into some high temperature regions
called hotspots which are the blobs that
you're seeing from this movie over
here and when there are sufficiently
many hot spots enough to you know um
create a self-sustaining combustion then
you know the things will start to blow
off uh but on the other hand when we
don't have enough hot spots um with you
know not enough strength or densities
then uh nothing is going to happen and
the the heat will just dissipate um and
you know uh that's kind of the Dynamics
that we're interested in over here so
for many reasons concerning the safety
and the performance of these energetic
materials uh understanding the number uh
predicting the number of hot spots and
then how fast they will grow uh is
actually a very important question
because uh if there are too many hotpots
um you know happening you know like um
evolving violently then that means the
material gets you know too sensitive and
even for a you know a small amount of
shock uh things will you know blow off
whereas if there is not enough hot spots
created then you know when the the
energy needs to be delivered it will
fail to deliver that energy and then you
know uh we're going to have an issue
over there so the adjusting the
sensitivity of the material is actually
a very critical um research question in
this area and then a lot of people are
actually work you know using computer
simulations to see how these hotpots
evolve uh under different um you know
shock input loading uh conditions or you
know based as a function of different
microscopic
structures but the problem is uh one
simulation usually takes about a day uh
or more on a DOD supercomputer so this
is kind of a devastating challenge if
you think about it because uh if you're
a person who's interested in the
relationship between the micr structural
design versus uh the hotspot Behavior
then what you would like to do is to
create a lot of you know uh
microstructure specimen and then run
computational simulations and then from
those data you would you know like to
see the trend uh in terms of you know uh
what are those micr structural
parameters that will determine the
number of hotspots created and and so on
and so forth but then if one simulation
takes you know such a long time then uh
it's going to be you know practically
impossible to understand that
relationship so um my research um you
know this particular project started
with this uh research question that how
can we approximate the governing
equation of the hotspot Dynamics as a
function of those micr
structures so what we first did was to
um Define this generic form of uh uh
Dynamics equation so here uh what you're
seeing is uh first of all uh mu uh is
the variable that represent the
morphology of uh the micro structure and
then X is basically our quantity of
Interest which in this case uh in our
case a temperature and pressure field uh
is represented by uh the vector
X and what this equation tells us about
is the relation the the rate of change
the Dynamics of uh the temperature and
the pressure change as a function of the
current temperature and current pressure
and the micr structure
morphology now uh the idea here is since
the relationship a is unknown um and we
don't really know the exact relationship
between the temperature uh Dynamics and
the the microscopic structures so uh the
you know the only thing that we can rely
on is basically uh some statistical
model uh parameterized by the variable
Theta over here in particular uh we
decided to use convolutional neural
network a type of a deep neural network
that a lot of people uh use to solve a
variety of different computer vision
problems so um in in some sense this is
sort of a computer vision problem
because our variable x uh is the
temperature field and it's basically
like a movie um that you saw from this
uh the previous slide so uh we thought
this would be a a nice and interesting
computer vision problem in some sense so
we decided to use convolutional NE
Network to to model the Dynamics and
then like I said uh earlier uh the the
variable Theta here is the model
parameter defining the convolutional
neural network so uh in our case this is
the unknown that we're trying to uh
trying to learn uh from a data set and
then the Epsilon over here uh is the
stochastic noise and the prediction
here now assuming that we can learn that
relationship uh as a parameter uh I mean
as a parametric function um of theta
then uh we can predict the future state
of the temperature field and the
pressure field as an integral as a Time
integral of that Dynamics over here so
the the dxdt gets integrated from uh uh
for a given time interval uh and then um
since we can model this dxdt using
convolutional neural network by
integrating the output of the uh the
convolutional neural network we should
be able to uh make a prediction of the
the future state of the of the material
system is basically the
idea now all of this idea uh at the end
of the day bowls down to this kind of a
neural network architecture where uh we
have the two main things over here so
the first thing is this purple box
called the differentiator CNN so that is
essentially the um the the dxdt over
here uh or the the convolutional neural
network f that models the Dynamics dxdt
so that's that's our purple box uh in
this diagram and what this purple box
does is to take the current temperature
and the pressure as an input alongside
the micr structure
geometry uh as an input and then makes a
prediction of the dtdt the
dxdt uh the the rate of change of
temperature the rate of change of
pressure as an output so that's what
what uh the differentiator CNN does and
then the integrator CNN uh is basically
a uh datadriven approximation of this
integral operator over here so by
integrating the output of the
differentiator CNN we can predict the
future state of the temperature field
and the pressure field so in this
diagram that's basically what we're
doing over here by taking this dxdt as
an input along alongside the current
temperature and the current pressure we
make a prediction of the future pre
future temperature and the future
pressure after a Time stap delta
T now what happens over here is we then
use the same differentiator CNN
recursively and then make a prediction
of the the the rate of change of
temperature and the rate of change of
pressure again and then we integrate
that to predict the temperature and the
pressure in uh you know uh after a Time
delta T again and then by recur you know
by repeatedly um applying this
differentiator and integrator uh we can
uh basically make a prediction of the
Dynamics how the temperature and the
pressure uh of this uh Hotpot Dynamics
evolve over time and then the training
is basically uh just the L2 loss or the
mean square error between the predicted
temperature uh and the ground through
temperature uh as well as the the
predicted pressure and the ground
through pressure and then those are
compared um literally pixel by pixel and
then uh the neural network uh so the
both differentiator CNN and the
integrator CNN learns the neural net
parameters to uh to minimize the
discrepancy between the prediction and
the ground
through so after training this algorithm
uh we were able to uh achieve a pretty
decent um prediction result so here what
you're seeing is the prediction result
of this algorithm which by the way is
called the physics aware recurrent
convolutions so uh or in other words
Park uh in short because uh here we have
a convolutional neural network
architecture that is uh recursively
applied uh over time so that's a
recurrent convolutions and then this is
indeed a uh physically inspired uh
neural network architecture so the name
uh physics
aware Now using this algorithm we can
actually uh do a pretty good job in
predicting uh the temperature dynamics
of um you know different micr structure
specimens so for uh in this slide what
you're seeing is for this given micr
structure specimen uh this is the
computation simulation result uh from
that expensive simulation which took you
know about a day on a supercomputer and
then here we see the prediction result
of the deep learning algorithm and then
as you can see that uh the the location
of hotspots and then their growth rates
are uh are very similar to the to the
ground through and then there are some
other um you know material specimens uh
with varying size of crystals uh
different
orientations uh different parties and
you know things like that and then as
you can see the hotspot patterns are all
you know different according to the micr
structural geometry and then as you can
see uh the park algorithm was able to
capture those you know different
locations and uh and
everything so quantitatively speaking uh
uh we could see that Park was able to uh
capture the Hot Spot Dynamics pretty
well uh except for the fact that it sort
of underestimated the absolute value of
the temperature uh about 500 Kelvin uh
but other than that uh we could see a
you know very good agreement between the
park predicted result and then the the
the ground through
simulation now you may think that well
still this is you know not perfectly
accurate and then uh you know this is
not giving uh you know perfectly valid
representation of the uh the real
physical phenomena but considering the
fact that the traditional you know more
accurate computer simulation takes about
a day on a high performance Computing
cluster versus Park requires less than a
second on a you know a regular laptop uh
that actually you know creates a huge
difference and at the end of the day you
know simulations are simulations so
simulations also are not uh the most
accurate representation of the physical
world uh and then you know considering
the the the the tremendous gain in the
computational speed um you know we can
we can say that uh this park algorithm
is actually quite beneficial uh in terms
of analyzing and you know predicting the
the hotspot temperature
Dynamics in energetic materials so this
kind of you know leads to a a disc about
the vision that the the big picture that
we're uh kind of you know thinking of um
and where my group is currently heading
towards so um as a matter of fact we are
using a lot of deep learning algorithms
to facilitate the process of you know
designing new functional materials and
Engineering material Properties by
changing the micr structures and things
like that so um what you're seeing here
is this you know relationship between
the the morphometric characteristics of
the micr structure uh versus the
Dynamics of uh of that donation and as
you can see uh in this particular
example we're comparing the you know
different sizes of uh hmx crystals and
as you can see for small crystals we get
to see a you know a lot more you know
violent and
dynamic uh you know process compared to
the larger
crystals and you know the Hope over here
is to use this kind of deep learning
algorithm to uh to create a design Loop
basically where we can uh find the sort
of a sweet spot in terms of the the
material M um the micromorphometric
let's say uh you're interested in
designing a material that has certain
Desir properties and perform performance
characteristics and what we are able to
do is to
create uh digital specimens or digital
twins of the materials uh using a deep
bake algorithm so this is a generative
AI um traditionally we used the
generative adversarial neural networks
but nowadays we're exploring also
diffusion modeling uh but this is
basically a deep fake algorithm that can
synthesize um synthetic micr structures
uh you know and then by using the
synthetic micr structures what we are
able to do is to uh rapidly estimate the
the physical performance of the material
using the algorithm like Park and then
you know by comparing the predicted
performance with the design
specification uh we can you know have
this kind of a design Loop where uh you
know our our algorithm is basically
modifying this um this this digital
Twain uh and the you know the design
parameter of the material specimen uh
until we get to reach the performance
characteristics that uh uh we're we're
looking to
achieve So speaking of um of deep fake
uh here's a little bit of overview of
our previous work uh where we developed
this generative adversarial Network that
uh takes in certain numerical parameters
to control control the uh the
morphometric characteristics of the
synthetic micr structure so it can not
only generate some realistic micr
structure specimen but also it can
control uh the properties of those
specimen so as you can see in this
example uh we can change the orientation
of the micro of the crystals we can also
change the size distribution of the
crystals uh and so on and so
forth now uh I would like to kind of
deep you know take take a deeper dive
into this physics aware machine learning
um learning business because you know at
the very core of this you know this
Grand Vision is this idea of machine
learning algorithm aware of physics so
what is physics aware versus physics
naive uh in other words why can I not
just use uh you know any other deep
learning algorithm to you know perform
the same task so I think think the
problem in the physics Community here in
adapting um you know deep learning and
all this you know progress in machine
learning is that the outputs of machine
learning algorithms are not guaranteed
to follow certain you know certain
physical rules uh so for example in
traditional mechanics we all know that
uh you know moving objects will follow
this you know rule defined by Newton
ethicals to ma uh but you know if you
just throw in data and then you know
pray for your neural network to learn
something about this relationship that
then the chance is you know the the
actual output of the neural network will
not necessarily follow this strict
relationship called f equals to Ma so uh
we're kind of seeing a similar situation
over here uh when it comes to the
material physics as well uh there are
certain governing rules and uh Dynamics
but if you just train a deep neural
network to learn that relationship then
uh the chance is it'll not be able to uh
learn that very well so as a matter of
fact we compared our our algorithm Park
against other uh physics naive
algorithms so one uh kind of you know
point of comparison was unet uh which is
you know very widely used in a variety
of different
applications and then here we have this
algorithm called the imagin Ator uh
which is a very famous video generation
algorithm uh in the computer vision
community so none of these two are
physically aware and as a result of that
uh first of all we can see that the you
know the growth rate of hotspot is not
necessarily um you know accurate
compared to the ground truth result and
then also interesting the in case of
imaginator especially U as you look at
this part over here the Dynamics is not
continuous so uh the physics naive
algorithms doesn't necessarily know this
continuous evolution of the temperature
field uh and then the the growth of
hotspots uh we could see that a lot of
this prediction result was kind of a um
you know fluctuating uh and sort of
discontinuous in terms of how you know
how the hotpots grow and how hot spots
you know appear and
disappear in order to uh further
validate the physics awareness of Park
uh we also kind of tested the algorithm
on the time steps that are not that were
not included in the in the in the
training data set so here what we were
seeing is the prediction result uh of
Park up to uh 27 nond um that sounds
like a very small number but uh in the
Dynamics of detonation that's actually
you know uh fairly long time step uh and
park was trained initially to predict up
to 15 nond time interval and then up to
that point uh it did a pretty good job
and then we were curious you know uh if
Park would be able to predict the the
Dynamics and the evolution of hotspots
Beyond these 15 NS and then uh we could
see that um you know it followed the
general trend of the hotspot evolution
uh quite well not only for this
particular micr structure but also a
variety of other micr structures and as
a matter of fact uh the plot was um I
mean the the quantitative validation was
also uh indicated that uh the predicted
uh result beyond the simulation time was
uh pretty accurate compared to the
ground truth except for the absolute
temperature value so interestingly
earlier I I I mentioned that it was
about 500 Kelvin sort of underestimated
in case of Park but then as we go beyond
um you know 15 nond you can see this
kind of you know the trend kind of flips
now you know Park sort of overestimate
the temperature so other than that um we
are generally happy with the result of
Park prediction and then I think this is
indicative of uh the physics awareness
of uh AR architecture
now uh I think uh many of you uh I mean
even in biomedical engineering um many
of you I think will be familiar with
this um recent um line of work called a
physics informed neural network or pin
uh and for those of you who are already
familiar with pen I think um it is um it
is right to sort of compare pin and park
and how they are different in terms of
learning the physics so
um you know in machine learning um there
are roughly three different you know
ways of learning physics from data uh
the first thing is observational bias
approach and observational bias approach
is um in some sense the most physics
naive approach where uh you just hope
the machine learning algorithm to learn
some physical rules from the data itself
and then there's no other intervention
uh commit into play so uh that is
probably the simplest um you know
approach but yet I think the most
physics naive approach uh which you know
I don't think is going to be very
effective I think um the the recent
physics and form machine learning um
research is uh primarily in the
direction of this learning bias approach
where the idea is uh the physics
governing equation is basically used as
a training loss in the back propagation
process and as a result of that uh the
pde residual is um is basically used to
update the neural network parameters so
that you know the neural network
prediction not only you know minimize
the the data error the prediction error
but also the residual of the governing
physics uh is kind of the learning bias
approach whereas um another sort of
approach that you can think of is what
is called the inductive bias approach
and this is basically this is basically
Park so in inductive bias approach what
we're hoping to achieve is to design a
specific neural network architecture
that inherently embed the physics rules
and principle in the architecture itself
so the differentiator integrator
architecture that I presented in part is
a good example of that inductive bias
approach now um in order to compare pen
and park uh here's a little toy problem
called the burgers equation this is um
probably one of the simplest um fluid
dynamics equation uh that is popularly
used in comput computational fluid
dynamics Community uh for validation um
of an algorithm so I'm not going to go
into the the niggr details of the the
the actual physical meanings of this but
uh the idea is given this governing
equation can pin and park uh learn this
uh this fluid dnamic
phenomena and this is kind of the result
of uh testing that hypothesis so here's
the ground truth initially we have a
gaan distribution of uh of this fluid
and then uh according to that Burger's
equation
uh I mean the Dynamics governed by the
burgers equation you can see this fluid
sort of moving toward the right bottom
corner and then we have uh the an
algorithm called the physics cret which
is basically a variant of one of the the
most recent variant of pin and then here
we have a park algorithm and as you can
see uh Park uh does a fairly good job of
U you know predicting the ground truth
um you know uh fluid dnamic Behavior Uh
defined by the burgers equation whereas
the physics crnet seem to have a little
bit of um you know this jigglin or the
the uh what should I call this the this
um uh grid like artifacts uh in the
prediction result but uh I think overall
um in terms of the performance
prediction performance I think both uh
Park and are um are quite good now um
when we further validate in investigated
the the prediction error and the
solution quality uh we could actually
see that the result of Park sorry I
forgot to include the legend but the
dashed line over here is the result
coming from Park and then the solid line
is the result coming from pin and then
uh we're plotting the error in a log
scale uh so the the top row is the
prediction error so this is the the data
loss and then the bottom row is the
residual of the governing physics so uh
again how you know far off the
prediction result from the uh the
physics defined by the burgers equation
is plotted at the bottom and then in
general Park seems to perform better
than uh the pin all
them and then you know as you can see
over here uh we plotted this um um this
scatter plot where the horizontal axis
is the PD residual and then the vertical
axis is the prediction error and then
the the red dots over here uh is the
result from Park uh which is um overall
more accurate in you know not only in
prediction eror but also in the PD
residual and then we have this physics
CR that result where um it is a little
bit off uh from this um you know why
goes to x uh line over here so uh that
is also sort of indicative of the fact
that Park is indeed uh physics
aware um you know compared to other
physics and form neural network
algorithms now I think um what is most
exciting about Park and especially in
the relation to biomedical applications
is that what if you don't know the
governing equation so like in case of
the burgers equation
example uh we already had this governing
equation analytically defined so we knew
everything about the Dynamics and then
the challenge was basically about how
well we can approximate that readily
known governing equation but I suspect
in a lot of problems in bedal uh
applications um we don't really know the
the governing equation defining the
Dynamics of biological systems at least
we only know you know partially uh what
the Dynamics look like so for those kind
of
situations uh can we still learn and
discover the governing equation is kind
of the uh reasonable question to ask and
my answer to that is yes uh we are
actually uh able to discover that uh the
the energetic material example is
actually an archetype of uh such problem
where we don't fully know the governing
equation of the material system so in
case of Park uh this is learned uh from
without knowing uh the actual governing
equation and then same thing over here
in case of pin again we train the
algorithm without actually telling uh
what the governing equation is because
we don't have the the full set of
governing equations uh for for for this
problem and as you can see over here uh
Park is still able to um you know
predict the hotspot Dynamics uh despite
the fact that we didn't know the
governing equation um you know in an
analytical
form so I you know again I cannot think
of a very specific biomedical
application but hopefully from uh from
this result uh you'll be able to um you
know connect the dots between uh what
I'm you know telling over here in the
material
uh example uh with um the the research
topic that you might be interested
in so uh for the interest of time uh let
me uh just move a little bit
um so um uh you another thing that I
want to you know present over here is
you know along the line of discovery of
uh physics governing equations um I
think uh the the the issues with deep
learning and deep neural network models
is that they're you know kind of a
blackbox and it's you know hard to
interpret and um what my group is
working on currently is to basically to
open up this black box and see if we can
find features that are actually useful
in describing the Dynamics uh over here
so uh one such example here is uh what
is called a salian map I I think a lot
of people are uh here in the audience
are familiar with this um techniques
called grad cam or ceny map techniques
and and things like that those are you
know one of the uh most you know widely
used uh machine learning VI I mean deep
learning visualization algorithms um to
reveal uh the the reasoning process of
uh deep neural network prediction so
long story short uh what saliency map
does does is to visualize uh where this
hot temperature regions comes from so in
other words what was the reason that the
neural network believed that there was
going to be a hot you know high
temperature
region and then we can uh uh we can use
a back propagation algorithm to sort of
track down uh what were the causes of
those high temperature regions in the
prediction result and this is kind of
overlay of uh those you know uh the
track down result where we highlighted
the image regions in the the input micr
structure image uh that the neural
network believes to have you know led to
the formation of hotspots and then uh
what's really interesting to me here is
that um you know even before all this
deep learning business the energetic
material Community has empirically
discovered that the the cracks and voids
uh are actually the the main players in
the detonation of uh energetic materials
so uh one thing that was um pretty
interesting to me was that uh uh you
know all this sanap result highlighted
the voids and cracks in the material
micr structures not the crystals
themselves so that I think is u um you
know indicative of the fact that you
know Park was actually able to to to
learn the Dynamics uh in a physically
you know meaningful fashion uh as
opposed to some random combination of
features but also uh another interesting
thing was so we we sort of um you know
plotted the saliency map and then some
voys were highlighted and some voys were
not highlighted so um you know which
meant that some of the boys were
critical in the formation of the hot
spots and then some voids were not you
know super critical in for in the
formation of hot spots so we've kind of
gathered those um what we call critical
voids and non-critical voids so critical
voids are the ones that are highlighted
by the saliency map and then
non-critical voids are the ones that are
not highlighted by the saliency map and
then we sort of compare them uh to see
if there's any meaningful difference um
and surprisingly I mean even from the
you know the glance of the Void geometry
even with the Naked Eyes we can see that
there's some difference between the
critical voids and the non-critical void
I think the most you know prominent
thing is that there's a certain size
distribution of the C critical voids
whereas non-critical voids are just like
everywhere in terms of the size and then
also you can see that the CR critical
voids are sort of you know uh sort of
lying flat whereas uh non-critical voids
have all kind of different orientations
you know some are vertical some are
slanted uh and so on and so
forth and when we quantitatively compare
the two uh we could actually find some
statistically meaningful Trends between
critical voids and non-critical voids so
right now we're uh we're actually
working with um you know more
theoretical U people um trying to
understand the physic of energetic
material um you know Dynamics and then
we're also working with um uh the
computational modeling people um to kind
of distill um a new set of Knowledge
from the result learned by a deep neural
network algorithm and that's kind of you
know uh one of the ways that an AI could
be useful for scientific discovery um
not only in Material Science but I think
in uh biomedical applications uh I think
you would be able to find those kind of
applications very
well so um that so far has been the
ongoing research and before I conclude
I'll um mention briefly some of the the
future directions that we're currently
working on um one of the let me let me
just skip this slide one of the critical
limitations of the first the earliest
version of Park uh was the fact that it
was only for diffusion dominant uh
phenomenon so uh we actually you know
had to normalize the evolution of the
temperature field so that we can get rid
of all the advection
phenomena and um you know as a result of
that uh for unnormalized data so for the
data that contains the advection terms
uh you can see the park versin one
doesn't do a very good job in U
predicting the dynamic so in order to
overcome that uh we recently um
developed this new version of Park where
we can now consider the advection and
reaction terms on top of the diffusion
dominant phenomena so uh we have this
momentum equation over here and the
energy equation uh and then by including
those two uh we were able to achieve a
lot better prediction result uh as you
can see over here so on the top row we
have the ground proof and then Park
version one you can see that it only
kind of captures the the the overall
growth uh of the pattern but it doesn't
really capture this you know like swirly
shapes uh as a result of the ection
whereas Park verion two seems to be
seems to be doing a much better job in
detecting
those and then another thing is um we
also wanted to um you know vary the
operating condition of the parks so
again the initial uh Park paper only
contained the result of uh a very
particular um shock loading condition
which was 9.5 gigap pasal and then uh
the initial version of Park uh wasn't
able to generalize to other operating
conditions so the idea that we also
explored is uh this idea of style Vector
in generative adversarial networks where
basically we uh intentionally biasing
the prediction result based off of some
scalar parameters so using this idea
what we were able to do is to bias the
prediction results so 9.5 gigap Pascal
is what uh you know Park was originally
trained for and then here's a you know
weaker shock loading and as a result of
that uh if you look at the Grand truth
we have a lot lesser you know hot spots
uh you know formed as a result of that
shock and then uh Park uh without having
to add a lot more data uh we were able
to uh make a pretty good prediction of
that uh phenomena uh by using this style
Vector idea uh and then same thing goes
with the you know much stronger shock
here where uh instead of 9.5 gigap
Pascal now we have 15 GPA and then uh as
you can see Park uh again without having
to you know add a lot more data we have
a pretty good you know prediction result
over here so these are kind of the the
ongoing uh direction of
research uh with that I think for the
interest of time I'll I'll just stop
here and then in case that you you know
there's any question from the audience
I'll be happy to answer those thank you
Ste Steve thank you so much this was
really really cool I really really like
this and from the point point of view of
like
biophysical systems where things like
this might be handy I would imagine
things like you know just like even if
it's like outside of the physical body
but like an
epidemiological application you know how
a virus might spread through a number of
individuals for example there's a famous
example called Fishers equation which is
uh sort of the propagation of a an Al
with a particular frequency spreading
through a population and so population
genetics folks look at models like that
there's also like metabolic processes or
gene expression where genes are being
you know kind of activated in a system
um uh with a relative to a pte um motor
responses from muscle fibers and how
those uh respond in a jointed system
like an arm or a leg or something like
that and then of course stuff that I
really like is uh you know neural Action
potentials um like hodkin Huxley models
which are also uh partial differential
equations and so there's all manner of
different pdes that exist in biophysics
and Physiology and uh you know various
other systems that these kind of things
would be very appropriate for I agree
age have you explored any of those no no
not at the moment so right now uh my
group is pretty busy with uh you know a
few of the grants from the Department of
Defense and the National Science
Foundation um highly focused on Material
Science research but we were actually
kind of
exploring um you know how we can kind of
expand our you know Horizon and then you
know find different applications and
then biomedical obviously was one of the
one of the direction that we were hoping
to um you know move forward to but um
not nothing you know very specific or
you know Tang at the moment so I'll be
open to you know ideas and suggestions
from the audience or even like uh you
know if there's anybody interested in
collaborating I'll be interested in
exploring those uh those ideas one of
the things which I think was
particularly interesting is that you
mentioned that you know
ordinarily solving some of these models
you know requires between 16 and 30
hours on a high performance Computing
system and with some of these models you
get a pretty good guess at least an
initial guess when in under a second
using commodity hardware and I'm kind of
just curious if when you then take these
methods and you put them on a
supercomputer you know you should one
probably get a very high fidelity answer
in you know no hardly any time at all
certainly better than 16 to 30 hours
have you done that and do you are you
able to to see those kind of performance
improvements so that that's a great
question Jack and um frankly that was
the initial kind of motivation behind
this research we wanted to come up with
a good initial estimate of the solution
so that we can you know like uh
accelerate the the simulation so the
idea is basically to you know make a a
rapid guess of the initial solution
using Park and then using that as an
input now the the more rigorous you know
physics code should be able to converge
to a rigorous solution in much faster
speed was the initial idea but then we
sort of came to this I don't know um not
not a conclusion but we we came to this
thought
that maybe that's um sort of an Overkill
uh when it comes to this particular
application because uh one you know
current missing block right now is that
we haven't validated this on an actual
physical experiments and and uh the
simulation model I mean simulation uh
model is also just a you know a
numerical uh characterization of some
you know actual physics and then um I
mean in the simulation Community there's
a saying that um you know no models are
are accurate but some models are useful
right so uh all models are basically
wrong so there there's certain you know
discrepancy between the real physics
versus what the simulation captures so
given that um like do we even want
to um you know achieve that incremental
Improvement you know of the park
prediction when you know the the
simulation will anyways give us some you
know erronous results so if that is
going to be the case why don't we just
use this as is and then you know try to
use it for you know something more
useful was kind of the you know the the
flow of thoughts but but yeah I mean
like your your idea of using part uh as
an initial condition for a simulation
solver is is perfectly valid and then
there there are as a matter effect uh
people you know trying to use neural
networks to boost the solution process
of partial differential equations so
that's perfectly um you know uh useful
idea that uh already a lot of people are
exploring one other thing is the um does
Park actually return to you a a solution
to the not a solution to the equation
but actually what the governing equation
happens to be so I mean what the
examples you show look like they're you
know producing a result which emulates
the underly you the physical thing that
you're trying to do but does it actually
spit back a thing saying you know oh
Dell two of some process is equal to the
you know basically it's that equation
but like for example what if if if it
were the wave equation would it be able
to return the form of the of the wave
equation for example so that that is a
wonderful question and that is in fact
uh a research problem of one of my posts
so right now I think the current
limitation of the you know this whole
physics and form machine learning
research not only Park but also you know
many other um you know machine learning
approaches I think their limitation is
that uh we're just giving a parametric
approximation of that unknown you know
governing equation sure and we only you
know
approximate the optimal configuration of
theta uh that defines the neural network
we don't really return the actual
ordinary differential sorry actual
governing equation terms so uh there is
a line of research in this area where
people are trying to figure out you know
what what is the functional form instead
of like this huge humongous set of
numerical values that defines you know
the neural network weights uh what are
the actual you know
meaningful uh physics governing equation
that are human interpretable is kind of
you know one of the direction that um
you know people are um heading into and
my group is kind of you know working on
the same you know sort of a problem
which is why you know the sany map
result that I presented
um in the the later part of this you
know presentation is also to sort of you
know open up this black box and then try
to you know uh distill uh you know more
useful form of equation as opposed to a
collection of you know millions of
neural network parameters so that is
kind of uh you know really interesting
uh research question for the future yeah
I really appreciate that because as you
know as you know you get out these
neural networks they have a gajillion
number of hidden layers and all the
connections between them and it
basically it's not the kind of it's not
very compact right you couldn't like go
and say oh here's the schinger equation
or here's the you know the the the the
heat equation which would be you know
those are the basis for a lot of
different physical models um or D
derivations thereof and you know we have
this very complicated data it would be
nice to be able to compr you know solve
them but then be able to show and here's
the canonical form of this as an actual
pte because some of the parameters of
those pdes are very important to
understanding the Dynamics of those
systems and I'm thinking of like speed
and and Signal say transduction velocity
or wavefront velocity um which give you
a lot of information about the Dynamics
of these systems and you described that
a little bit in one of your earlier
examples um but you know having it in
that final form would be very very handy
so that's right that's right so like
going back to this slide I mean you know
at the current stage we're not able to
give this you know specific form of
equation here but we can uh predict the
force uh for example very well with some
blackbox you know machine learning
algorithm that takes you know the mass
and the distance as an input but yeah
currently we're unable to tell this you
know very specific form of equation so
well I it sounds like you are well on
your way Steve so uh we're at the top of
the hour so I want to thank you again
Steve for uh really giving us an
inspiring talk because this is really
this is really cool stuff because it
really F you know puts a foundation onto
some of these blackbox neural network
approaches that you know they give us an
answer that looks great but it doesn't
have any you know like you sort of said
we sort of trust that these things may
have some bearing in reality and it
would be actually nice to have them you
know physically informed so that we can
actually put some more trust in them so
thank you for sharing this great work
and thank you for giving us a lot to
think about uh and so thank you again
and thanks to everybody who joined us
and have a wonderful weekend absolutely
thank you so
much